foreign
let's go to Maddie in Omaha what's up
Maddie
hi Mr Dawn Delaney thank you for taking
my call you got it what's up
um okay if you don't mind I wrote
everything down because I didn't want to
mess this up
um it's so good I appreciate you doing
that because I should probably do that
more all right go for it you need to so
um okay so my mother and father-in-law
have been married for over 50 years
they're in their 70s
um if you ask anyone to tell you that
they're just the nicest people you'll
ever meet always smiling working hard
they had four kids and now loads of
grandkids
um they just kind of appear to have it
all uh it's this however is not the same
behind closed doors
I don't know the extent of it but I fear
that it gets pretty bad and I don't want
to be right but I don't want to stir the
pot if I'm wrong
um since marrying my husband 20 years
ago their son my mother-in-law has tried
to run away driving several states away
even getting a different phone she has
also tried to end her life but was found
in time taken to the hospital
nobody outside of the immediate family
knows about that
um I overheard him yelling at her one
time when he didn't know that I was in
the house
and she was silent the entire time and
as soon as he saw me he stopped
um a couple years ago I noticed she had
bruising around her eye
that she tried to cover up with makeup
and when I asked her about it she gave a
strange explanation but I just thought
well it must be possible so I let it go
and then a couple weeks ago they came
over and I saw she had a huge bruise
that was like a band around her arm
right above her elbow and it looked like
she tried to cover it up with makeup and
I asked her about what happened
and she got really flustered as if she
was like searching for an answer and she
just said she fell and that she bruises
easily
but it didn't make sense because it was
a band around her arm
um my question is questions are what if
I'm wrong and what if I'm not and if I'm
not wrong but I say something and she
doesn't want to do anything about it
they've been married for 50 years you
know that
like I just don't I don't know the steps
to take
yeah thank you for
thank you for being brave and and
um writing all that out you know it's
hard to put down on paper because you
look at it and all of a sudden your
heart starts beating like I gotta do
something right
um my big first question is well let me
just say this you have to do something
okay so that ship has sailed and now
we're going to figure out what that is
um
your husband lived with this he knows
why is he avoidant or doesn't want to
get involved
I've brought it up several times and I
feel like
they kind of try to keep everything
seeming that perfect happy life even for
their kids and grandkids and so
I think he just fears messing all that
up so his mom's about his mom's about to
be dead
all right
like so this little fear of I just don't
want to ruffle feathers moms you're
about to go to a funeral
right that was wholly preventable
that's what I fear and so I look at
these things behavior is a language
so when somebody's running away somebody
thinks in their mind I would rather not
be here at all
than be in this
that is somebody yelling as loud as they
can but without the words
help
right and I'm disappointed in in their
kids
and somebody's got to do something
someone's got to step up somehow okay as
far as
um three of their kids don't live
anywhere near yeah but but they they
know they grew up in this house this
doesn't just happen
that's what I wonder but yeah I don't I
don't know if things changed after
everyone moved out or okay let me ask
you this did it was was heard was your
father-in-law rough on your husband
growing up
he was strict in rules and iron hand but
he didn't
he wasn't that physically abusive like
my husband can point out one time that
his dad did something
what about the has your husband ever
told you about times he hit mom
no never that's why that's why it's
confusing to me is because I I always
thought well they would know something
and but I mean usually it was just a
bunch of yelling and
but he never really mentions physical
stuff which is why I fear that I'm Maybe
I'm Wrong in reading into things
so here's my philosophy as always
and here it My Philosophy is very biased
because I've been on the other side of
this and I've been wrong
so when it comes to perceptions of abuse
it comes perceptions of suicidal
ideation
I have made the choice in my life that
I'm gonna err on the side of asking too
many questions and I'm turning on too
many lights then not doing enough
okay that's just the choice I've made
you don't have to make that same choice
um what I would do if I'm in your
situation is I would tell my husband
I have seen bruises on under her eyes
I've seen bruises on her body that she's
trying to cover up and when I ask her
about it as a woman I know she's not
telling me the truth
I know she's covering for somebody
and so I'm going to ask her directly are
you safe
and I would y'all live in the same town
yes me and my husband live in the same
kind of some okay
um
I would take her to breakfast or I'd
take her to lunch and I would say I'm
gonna be very direct with you because I
love you
and I consider you a mom almost as close
as my real mom
and
I have a woman's intuition that you're
not okay
tried to run away you tried to die by
Suicide you've got bruises when you come
over to my house that you're covering up
are you safe
are you okay
and you were very very right she might
say I'm 50 years in that's just him if I
just was quieter then he wouldn't get so
angry that's how those
she's a grown-up she can make that
choice at some point it becomes elder
abuse
and I know there's some different Power
hierarchies in yada yada
if somebody is unable to take care of
themself and they are being abused I'm
gonna let somebody know
and at the end of the day this this
might end with you calling the police if
you tell her hey the next time I see
bruises on you
I'm calling somebody
okay right and it might be you call it
for a welfare check and she lies to the
police officer she lies to the social
worker and she she does that but at
least you will have sent a message to
everybody involved is I'm watching and I
love you seemingly more than anybody
else in this in this fear
and also also be open to being
completely wrong okay
she might tell you no I I I know how
this looks and it's not what you think
it is okay
um but your guts tell you something's up
don't they
yes absolutely okay
uh
uh here's here's what other siblings
into it or like the spoken to my husband
but I haven't talked with any of his
siblings no I would make this a very
personal
woman-to-woman conversation
okay
um I've had conversations with grown men
before
we've just gone out to lunch or gone to
grab a drink or something and I've said
hey
um this isn't technically my business
but I'm choosing to insert myself into
this
if you talk to
so and so again like that we're gonna
have a problem
or I'm not gonna bring me and my kids
and my family around this I love you and
I like being your friend like hanging
out you can't talk to women like that
not in my presence not presents of my
kids
and if this goes down she's welcome to
come stay with me you are not I've had
that conversation a few times and it
hasn't been awkward because a I had a
relationship with these folks and I
wasn't trying to like be like yeah bro
we're gonna fight out in the park I had
nothing to do with that
just had to do with hey this is right
and I've had people do that for me
right like hey John like what you're
doing right now is not right it's not
who you want to be it's not how you say
you are as our friend group it's not who
uh We've agreed we're gonna be this
needs to stop now does that make sense
so I've had people reach out and tell me
they love me in that way and so that's
that's all you're doing here
it's a private conversation
and so if I if if I have this discussion
especially with her
and she kind of just laughed it off
because I'm going to kind of picture her
doing like is that pretty much that's
all I could do and I back off no I think
I think you let her know
um
I understand this is scary and if you've
lived with us for a long long time
um I I I I understand how big of a deal
this is
I need you to hear me say if I see
bruises on you again
um I'm gonna call somebody
okay if you want me to go with you to
make a report if you want me to go with
you to sit down and tell your husband
you're no longer allowed to hit me
anymore
I'll go with you
um are your husband her son will come
with us too
so it's the after it's the I see what's
going on here I love you I'm with you
and
here's what I'm going to do next
okay does that make sense all right yes
and she might not be able to tell you
when it happens again
but she might show up if she knows
you're gonna call
she might show up that very next morning
after she gets hit the next time
and let you see that bruise
and that's her screaming help
with words she doesn't know how to say
does that make sense
yes absolutely
um
that phone call to the police is not a
he's beating her up whatever it is hey
I've got concerns and I feel like I
would sleep I'm just gonna sleep better
knowing that I made the call and that I
reached out on behalf of somebody that I
care about
um
my mother-in-law keeps coming to the
house with bruises I've been in the
house where there's a rage screaming
um I'm fearful that she's being abused
I've talked to her about it she said she
said no no it's okay
um something's not right I would like
y'all to do a welfare check on her
throwing grenades at him I'm not this is
purely on me this is what I'm seeing
this is what I'm feeling and my
intuition says something frightening is
going on and by the way let's remember
this intuition is simply your body
remembering
uh what it has seen before
have you seen this before
uh yes yep that's what intuition is
okay
well I appreciate it because I just felt
lost I felt like I was supposed to go
with my husband that when he didn't
really when he kind of brushed it off I
didn't really know where to go from
there so yeah and it it maybe that he
truly doesn't know it may be that he
didn't really take it seriously he may
be he may know
oh oh Maddie if we open this if we open
this box it's world war three
and I would continue to remember y'all
are about to go to a funeral
okay all right well thank you is that
cool yeah thank you so much for caring
and loving those in your community
and to everybody listening who's going
like oh my gosh you need to mind her own
business whatever
look around
look around
this is the culture we've got with that
kind of attitude
if somebody thinks I'm beating up my
wife I hope to God they will step in
front of me and call me on it
there's a great story that we did a few
um man it's maybe six or seven months
ago it was a great story where
um a guy was walking into a grocery
store and his was carrying his daughter
over his back and she was kicking and
screaming and hollering or no carrying
him out of a store and she was kicking
screaming and a man walking into the
store in the parking lot stopped and
said honey are you okay are you safe
and she's like no no turns out I don't
remember what the exact like she wanted
to buy something in the store and she
threw a temper tantrum and Dad's like
we're getting out of here
but that Dad who was carrying his
daughter out said Thank God somebody in
the parking lot stopped and saw a
screaming kid to make sure everything
was okay
that's the community that we need with
one another man
we're not not being involved like not
being involved putting our heads down
and walking it's not helping man it's
not helping
and I don't want a whole bunch of people
going to a funeral that was they don't
need to be going to
Step Up Step Up have the hard
conversation
your community needs you